leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu adam 9 bio leute ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut ich sitze hier
wieder auf dem sofa weil ich viel
erzählen werde viel erzählen muss es
wird trotzdem glaube ich super
interessant deswegen ist es sehr wichtig
ich brauche euch heute merkt sonst sonst
brauche ich eigentlich nicht mal einen
teiler spaß bevor wir starten wir haben
den adventskalender am laufen heute wird
natürlich wieder was krasses verlost und
ich dachte mir heute machen wir einmal
folgenden demand markurth die lächelt
mich sowieso die ganze zeit schon an wir
haben hier nintendos wii kleid mit
animal crossing in der farbe türkis so
ich persönlich hat auch super gerne so
eine aber ich habe keine und dies auch
halt für euch deswegen einfach kanal
abonnieren abonnent sein und jeden
kommentar schreiben ihr könnt so viel
schreiben wie ihr wollt am ende also gut
halten nicht zu viel spam aber am ende
lässt sich so ein programm drüberlaufen
nicht irgendein kommentar wird dann
einfach ausgewählt und dann bin ich dann
an und die person hat gewonnen deswegen
gerne ab und zu rein schauen ob ihr
angebot wurde oder nicht so viel dazu
will kommen jetzt aber zu den laptops
ich habe vor zweieinhalb drei wochen
zehn laptops bestellt aus polen wenn ihr
das video noch nicht gesehen habe wo ich
die ausgepackt habt schaut euch
unbedingt vorher das waren weil sonst
ist hier die spannung total weg glaube
ich deswegen einfach mal ich verlinke in
der beschreibung deckt das vorher ab das
waren alles restposten laptops gute
laptops gute ja die hatten sogar touch
zum teil alle von der marke lenovo ich
habe dafür insgesamt 1380 euro bezahlt
mit versand hierhin also das war der
preis den ich dafür bezahlt habe und ich
habe jetzt alle verkauft und ich bin
einfach selber mal extrem gespannt ob
sich das gelohnt hat wie viel haben wir
gewinn gemacht wie viel aufwand hatte
ich jetzt hier durch ein bisschen vor
allem auch wer hat gekauft und wo können
wir den gewinn rein investieren oder das
ganze geld damit wir noch mehr geld
verdienen weil das ist so ein bisschen
das ziel was ich verfolgen möchte
einfach mit so ein paar zwielichtigen
geschäften spaß das einfach so ein
bisschen auf youtube zu dokumentieren
wir starten einfach mal mein ansatz ist
es ja gewesen die laptops ich kann euch
gerne hier noch mal ein foto an wänden
auf ebay und amazon zu verkaufen dass
wir halt die einfachste möglichkeit
gewesen ich wollte aber auch meinen
zuschauern die möglichkeit geben wenn
die irgendwas davon gebrauchen können
bietet sich das natürlich an das erst
mal an euch zu verkaufen weil warum soll
ich das denn
in fremden verkaufen und daraufhin habe
ich diese instagram seite erstellt habt
da die fotos hochgeladen von den laptops
ich kann euch das gerne vielleicht hier
nochmal kurz einblenden
wir hatten insgesamt 5 chromebook sich
verkauft haben zwei davon mit uk
schlecker das wusste ich am anfang gar
nicht da musste ich an sich noch einen
neuen stecker kaufen für weil sonst
kannst du das hier halt nicht in die
steckdose stecken also das kann noch so
ein paar kosten auf mich zu das erzähle
ich aber alles dann hatten wir zwei mal
noch das chromebook hunderte und dann
noch einmal das chromebook 5 hundert das
habe ich am höchsten angesetzt und zwar
im internet wie das gehandelt für 450
euro allerdings mit 64 gb ich hatte nur
32 gb und wollte dann für 300 euro
verkaufen
genau und das habe ich gemacht der
ansturm auf die laptops über diese
internetseite war gewaltig also ich habe
am abend so reingeguckt weil ich dachte
da ich habe da ja die seite erwähnt
einfach schon direkt 99 bloß anfangen
ich würde ihn natürlich würde ich will
den job klappt den laptop und ich war
mir am anfang ein bisschen unsicher das
vielleicht auch viele jüngere dabei
sondern die mich vielleicht noch
verarschen wurde oder einfach nur mal
mit mir schreiben wollen aber nein
großes kompliment es war super easy ich
habe mit vielen coolen leuten gesprochen
alles entspannen sie haben direkt das
geld überwiesen und ja für mich ich
hatte vielleicht zu drei tage aufwand
damit ein bisschen mit den leuten zu
beschreiben den die überweisungsdaten zu
geben und dann war das geld auch schon
da und wir haben das geld von jedem
bekommen bis auf von einem aber das
müsst ihr auch unterwegs sein
deswegen das ist jetzt noch nicht dabei
aber ich würde das trotzdem einfach mal
plus addieren um gleichheit auf einen
guten betrag zukommen passt so ganz
wichtig ich habe auch an bekannte und
freunde von mir laptops verkauft einfach
weil die auch interessanten und ich
dachte mir gut nimm dir erst mal mache
ich die route freundschaftspreis zum
beispiel dann hat das war der erste
käufer am ersten tag also direkt am
nächsten tag hat er gekauft er kam
vorbei hat sich angeguckt nimmt da
jemand kurzer ausschnitt ja hallo mein
geld es wird nur
natürlich leute werden wir den nächsten
interessanten kennt ja wahrscheinlich
noch oder viele von euch an begriffe
brauchst du denn für die schule also der
hat mich direkt kontaktieren meinte ich
solle mir einen reservieren wir gucken
jetzt gerade mal wieder dass hier sehr
gut
man muss sich nämlich hier anmelden
einfach mit seinem google konto oder so
denn man kann sich auch ein konto
erstellen wir sind nähmlich echt ein
paar dinge aufgefallen
an den geräten mit denen ich nicht
gerechnet habe um ehrlich zu sein das
erkläre ich euch gerne mal ruhe aber ist
natürlich gar kein problem wir haben das
alles gefixt und damit die kunden
natürlich auch zufrieden sind aber immer
gut 80 jahre was man halt noch sagen
muss die chromebooks die sind halt alle
android betrieben dh die ab dem place
tor drauf und so alles ist natürlich
hier auch touch also es ist halt
eigentlich wie ein großes handy ich
denke mal dass es perfekt für deine
schule und wenn du nicht zufrieden
bekommen du zurück zu mir ich mache dir
gute preis an freunde und bekannte
verkaufe ich die für 200 euro die dinge
also die chromebooks hier zähne sind das
hier 20 40 90
ich würde jetzt gern sagen reicht aber
ich muss ist wichtig für das fürs video
fünf euro sonst machen wir so danke
danke
die ersten 100 95 euro sind angesagt ja
du bist der erste also die meisten
machen halt überweisungen muesste du
bist der einzige der mir das so gibt und
mein bruder möchte auch hin haben wir
nur noch wenig bis dahin welt kommen
dazu mir gute preis- und zwei
chromebooks habe ich dann noch für 200
euro an weitere bekannte verkauft was
allerdings ziemlich scheiße war moment
habe ich mich auch wirklich sehr darüber
geärgert dass ist ein chromebook 100 128
gigabyte in gold für 180 euro verkaufen
ich hatte auch einen käufer geld war
schon da bist mir aufgefallen ist der
geht nicht der ist kaputt da fällt eine
festplatte das wusste ich nicht dass
heißt dann habe ich noch und daran habe
ich leider noch kein gewinn gemacht habe
ich leider auch nicht mehr so viel
rausholen wenn jemand von euch gerne
haben würde und eine festplatte rein
schrauben will und denen dann
meinetwegen verkauft würde ich bin euch
hier an für 100 euro es fehlt wirklich
nur die festplatte und dann funktioniert
das dann auch wieder
also ich freue mich hier ist jetzt schon
mal das ganze geld drin
das geld was ich in bar erhalten habt
und das geld was ich gestern von der
bank abgehoben hat ich habe allerdings
heute morgen noch eine überweisung in
höhe von 210 euro bekommen und eine
weitere über 210 euro fehlt auch noch
also 410 euro kann ich noch darauf
addieren auf den betrag der herz raus
kommen ich bin echt gespannt ich hoffe
natürlich es ist so viel wie möglich ich
habe vorher noch nicht gezählt wir
kippen das einfach mal hier aus so viel
geld auf einer hand hatte ich schon
lange nicht mehr live bei mir wie gesagt
420 euro fehlen noch die werden noch
addiert und ich vielleicht tue ich auch
direkt schon die 100 euro für dieses
ding dazu weil ihr werde das gar nicht
mitbekommen wenn ich das dann irgendwann
verkaufe 100 110 130 150 170 180 200 220
225 275 375 425 445 495 ok 595 695 795
895 995 1095 1195 plus 420 landen wir
bei 1615 es hier noch die 100 euro
rechne ich jetzt einfach mal dazu wenn
ich die von irgendjemandem bekomme
landen wir bei 1715 euro ein guter
betrag ich bin zufrieden muss ich sagen
ich meine ich habe 1380 euro darin
investiert einen laptop wurde verlost
der fällt außer wertungen das heißt wir
können hier jetzt ungefähr nochmal 1242
euro muss ich glaube ich abziehen dann
landen wir bei 473 euro gewinn ich habe
gesagt ich setze 500 euro gewinn an hat
leider nicht ganz geklappt weil ich auf
einige abstriche machen musste und was
noch dazu kommt wir müssen hier noch
folgendes abziehen einmal den versand
ich musste fünf pakete verschicken alle
versichert - 37 eur 45 und dann nochmal
- 15 euro weil ich noch zwei ladekabel
kaufen musste die halt eine deutsche
steckdosen passen und die mit diesen uk
dingern ersetzen musste landen wir bei
420 euro 55 gewinnen ich denke dass ich
an sich eine gute summe mit der richter
rausgegangen bin da kann ich mir auf die
schultern trotzdem muss ich sagen war es
auch wirklich aufwändig und sehr
stressig ich meine wenn du hier einfach
zehn laptops rumliegen hast dann musst
du die irgendwie alle mal checken du
musst die alle auf machen alle ladekabel
überprüfen dann auch wieder alle in den
richtigen karton
das sind also ich bin oft durcheinander
gekommen und dann müssen noch adressen
darauf das muss alles zugeordnet werden
also es war schon ein bisschen aufwand
ich würde sagen ich habe das safe
so 8 stunden investiert um mit den
ganzen leuten zu schreiben die sachen
zur post zu bringen hier vielleicht mal
ein kurzer ausschnitt einer guten morgen
leute sind geld von allen ist da auch
von einem aber dem vertraut haben wir
das morgen kommt hinter mir sicher jetzt
die letzten pakete die werden jetzt zur
post gebracht
dann ist das projekt endlich abgehakt es
war echt aufwendiger als ich gedacht
hätte aber ich muss jetzt schnell zur
post weil ich habe heute noch einiges zu
tun dass steht als erstes opfer ist also
gestern war ich wirklich den ganzen tag
selben stress und habe mich eigentlich
nur um die laptops gekümmert trotzdem
420 euro gewinn teilen was man durch
acht das heißt ich habe ihren
stundenlohn von 52 euro erzielt also da
kann man nicht meckern und das waren ja
auch coole videoprojekte es ist super
wichtig leute ich habe jetzt hier diese
1700 irgendwas euro um rund fliegen 1115
glaube ich möchte in weitere projekte
investieren die cool werden ich habe mir
auch schon so ein paar ideen gesetzt ich
bin aber auch super dankbar wenn ihre
vorschläge habt wo ich das vielleicht
irgendwie rein stecken soll ihr ein
investieren soll was auch immer weil
theoretisch kann ich den betrag der auch
teilen und bisschen darin steckt ein
bisschen darin stecken
ich habe mir ausgesucht was ich
unfassbar gerne machen würde ich möchte
konsolen ware restposten auch wieder aus
polen bestellen sieht super interessant
aus dass dann wieder gewinnen bringt auf
meiner instagram seite zu verkaufen und
ja mal schauen was mir noch so einfällt
wenn ihr ideen ab schreibt bitte in die
kommentare das ist super wichtig und das
war's dann nach oben wir leisten nimmt
am gewinnspiel teil und wir sehen uns
übermorgen wieder gibt's zum nächsten
part vom adventskalender
danke fürs zuschauen drei leute